[Musique]
la république en marche at elle fait un
coup de force hier à l'assemblée tout
commence à 15h avec l'élection des trois
questeurs ceux qui tiennent les cordons
de la bourse de l'hémicycle normalement
une simple formalité mais coup de
théâtre
monsieur thierry solère 306 voix je le
proclame questeur de l'assemblée
nationale thierry solère du groupe dé
constructif prêt à travailler avec
emmanuel macron est élu alors que la
tradition veut que l'un des trois
questeurs fasse partie de l'opposition
le patron du groupe l'est républicain
est scandalisé les droits de
l'opposition viennent d'être bafoués
comme ils n'ont jamais été bafoués dans
cet hémicycle franck riester dé
constructif se défend il ya eu une
élection prévue par le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale il ya eu un vote
trois questeurs ont été élus où est le
déni de démocratie monsieur jacob
christian jacob annonce que l'est
républicain boycotte le bureau de
l'assemblée un coup d'éclat qui entraîne
une nouvelle suspension de séance elle
va durer près de trois heures
la séance est reprise il est 22h30 la
république en marche ça arrange les
postes de vice-président de l'assemblée
mais affirme qu'il s'agit d'un
remplacement temporaire ce que nous
proposons par ailleurs c'est de
respecter les droits de l'opposition
lorsque la bouderie aura cessé parce que
l'élection d'un questeur aura mal tourné
jean lassalle tente d'apaiser
l'atmosphère afin d'essayer de trouver
une solution
je présente aussi la canéda tueur
mais les coups de gueule sans chaînes
cette fois à gauche et ans peut-être
plus que c'est que cette façon de
fonctionner qu'est ce que c'est ça la
nouveauté
le nouveau monde la nouvelle politique
que voulait introduire par cet hémicycle
franchement il ya des moments où on est
plus fier d'être député que ce soit il
est minuit 30 sur six vice présidents
élus ce sens ils viennent de la
république en marche signe d'apaisement
aujourd'hui la présidence de la
commission des finances revient à eric
woerth des républicains mais le groupe
plaide toujours pour une nouvelle
élection
[Musique]